[Musique]
dans laquelle j'ai le plus l'air d'un
homme de harvard j'ai le plaisir
d'annoncer que tu n'a en rien l'air d'un
homme de harvard
bienvenue à la faculté de droit que je
m'appelle roues spyder ginza qu'est ce
qui vous amène mademoiselle ginsberg
vous occuper une place qui aurait pu
être attribuée à un homme il n'y a pas
plus intelligent que toi tu n'as qu'à
dire ce que tu sais monsieur fitzpatrick
il ya huit jours on m'a dit que les
femmes étaient trop émotif pour être
avocat que tu peux pas vendre un des
recruteurs m'a dit qu'ils avaient engagé
une femme l'an passé et qu'il ne voyait
pas ce qu'ils feraient avec 2 vous êtes
furieuse tant mieux servez vous en il
existe 178 lois qui font une différence
sur la base du sexe il ya des lois qui
interdisent aux femmes de faire des
heures sup il doit y avoir le nombre
marie sur nos cartes de crédit n'est pas
autorisé à prendre nous interdit de
travailler dans les mines
tu parles d'une ouverte la question
n'est pas là on devrait avoir le droit
[Musique]
convaincre les tribunaux fédéraux que
c'est une boisson anticonstitutionnelle
je ne lis pas les affaires de droit
fiscal
l'islande la loi stipule que la personne
qui s'occupent d'un proche doit être une
femme c'est de la discrimination fondée
sur le sexe contre un homme alors le
juge tôt monsieur moritz c'est la noix
14 égalité des genres en tant que droits
civiques mail cette affaire représente
une énorme opportunité pour les hommes
et les femmes
tu ne peut que perdre route en faisant
reculer de dix ans le mouvement de
libération de la femme
ce n'est pas toi de me dire d'abandonner
regardez plutôt les jeunes comme elle
ils descendent dans la rue pour exiger
que ça change
vous feriez bien de ne pas oublier que
c'est un privilège
ça n'a rien d'un privilège c'est une
cache et ses lois en ce sens les farro
patatras jacques
tu es prête ma chérie tu es prête pour
cet instant depuis toujours
nous devons éliminer ces lois une par
une
ça ferait tomber ce système de
discrimination inadmissible le mot fan
n'apparaît pas une seule fois dans la
constitution des états unis
pas plus que le mot liberté monsieur le
juge
[Musique]